foreign
season ping is facing a huge dilemma
with anti-code zero protests flaring up
across the country
[Music]
[Applause]
he's up with few good options a rapid
exit from cover zero could field with
surge in depth or a Crackdown on the
protest
heavy police presence has since kept
protesters away the question is how will
cease government respond
it's been almost three years of strict
coveted rules lockdowns and endless
rounds of testing that have kept China
largely isolated from the rest of the
world
she has staked his personal reputation
on its success keeping death to a
minimum compared to the West
but now some residents in China have had
enough and have taken to the streets to
call for change
the widespread protests in these numbers
and coordinated like this is extremely
rare
I would say that in general that the
Communist Party underestimated anger at
a garageful level is a value-related
some people want Community party to be
changed and also even more than that so
I would say that there is very very much
different from the past to some extent
it's quite similar to 1989 incident
the immediate Catalyst was a deadly fire
in a high-rise building sing Zhang
speculation swirled that coveted rules
blocked Aid and firefighting efforts
many of the protesters are young people
in their 20s and 30s and female the
protests are more than just about covid
they reflect the years of pent-up
frustration at the social and economic
toll of C's Code Zero policy
recovery strategy is his signature
public policy it's impossible to change
but in the meantime the anger is very
strong I would think some sort of soft
tongue approach may be adopted by some
local government but I'm not quite sure
because of you could see that the
people's daily published many articles
in Houston that the local strategy
should be embraced in China she's the
one who has insisted on the Zero
Tolerance approach to controlling coven
he's not nearly as secure as his beaming
countenance to the world at Big meetings
would lead you to believe he has to
worry about Rivals who would look for a
so-called mistake that he makes in order
to pull him down from Power
vaccination rate from China still like
those in other countries and the
exclusive use of less effective
domestically produced shots makes its
elderly population vulnerable
number one is to boost the vaccination
rate among older people number two is to
expand their health care facilities
China announced moves to focus on
elderly vaccinations
we must correct the wrongful practices
of arbitrary imposition of restrictions
and provide services to people to meet
their needs we also Advocate rapid and
active vaccination particularly the
elder population so as to protect
yourself and your family
for now sensors are working at full
speed to control internet comms to make
it harder for protesters to organize
[Music]